I'm curious as somebody who has lived
like the life that you've lived in comes
from the cloth that you're cut like
you're cut from how do you feel about
you know this there's a lot of snitching
going on in hip-hop obviously yeah 100
you know the YSL situation yeah there's
just a lot going on
man I think you people got to understand
I think sometimes we expect too much
from a lot of these dudes
you know what I'm saying just because
they're talking about something like I
mean we see Joe Pesci in all kind of
mobs and movies we know he's not a
monster true real life so it's the same
thing it's entertainment so when you see
these other guys you gotta understand
they're just rapping about stuff they
haven't really probably lived that life
right especially dudes to get on when
they're like 19 20 years old it's like
what have you experienced you know what
I'm saying like it's not too much you
can it's not like too much dirt you
actually probably did you know what I'm
saying so it was kind of like I think we
expect too much from them and
what's weird to me is why people get
money and want to go back to the streets
which is a big insecurity
you know what I'm saying like people get
money and want to be tough I'm trying to
get money and be soft like you know what
I'm saying I'm trying to get money and
be out the way you know what I'm saying
[__] with some kids you know what I'm
saying [__] like that you know what I'm
saying living life how you're supposed
to people are moving backwards yeah like
you're getting some money and they want
to go back down to the hood just like
that doesn't make any sense it's stupid
as hell and when they do that they end
up getting caught in situations yeah
like even like like you know we lost
someone like takeoff who's one of my
favorite rappers and it was like
you're a millionaire shooting dice yeah
like in the city like a city you're not
from why are we shooting dice like go to
the casino yeah I wouldn't I don't even
gamble but I wouldn't that's something I
wouldn't is it hard not to gamble and
live in Vegas no
no I've gamble with my money otherwise
I'm cool he's like actually like I got
other ways to Camp
I've again with my money way too many
other ways to give it away for free man
that's fair yeah yeah now the gambling
[__] I was never a gambler until I lived
there and then
really you start gambling oh yeah
I I mean there's a lot of lights out
there man it's a lot of electricity
bills they paying off more than one way
too
I got to Vegas and I just discovered a
whole other world I was like oh my God
yeah it's like you went fast I didn't
suck me in I was pretty like
level-headed the whole time but like I
you know you just like there's real
culture in Vegas that people will never
understand unless you live there for
sure for sure because you always hear
people like man Vegas ain't got no
cultures just casinos I'm like that's
not true like you have to really live
there and understand that like there is
like real Vegas culture that and it's a
city that breeds like hustle yeah for
sure like you have to like if you grew
up in Vegas for sure even if you end up
being a valet guy you're making it six
figures if you're at the right casino
like if you're if you're a beautiful
girl in Vegas
that's the one thing I always thought
man if I ever had a daughter I could
never be in Vegas because never the
chances of her being a stripper or a
bottle girl
are very high 90 percent
it's like man and I've seen the
progression I remember I was like [__]
with a [__] when she was like working
at like
Little Darlings right and then she'll
end up at the Rhino and then she'll end
up on the Internet
man I see it all the time it's crazy
though but um a lot of people don't
understand that man like
Vegas is one player I've been to a lot
of cities and but Vegas is one place
where I've seen a lot of young young men
and women riding around foreigns and big
like big Lifestyles like at an early age
you know what I'm saying it's a city
like if you know if you know how to get
money you get money there yeah it's a
real hustle City for real for sure how
do you feel like um with like you know
obviously it's become like now the
Raiders are there yeah the Las Vegas
aces are there they're talking about the
NBA team they're talking about the
Oakland A's might be coming it does feel
like it's growing exponentially but it
also feels like
skin commercial yeah yeah I mean it's
all you know there's always been an
element of that but for you like how do
you feel about like the growth like I
mean I mean good for your real estate
value yeah it's it's good and um
as long as they can come out you know a
lot of Raiders dudes getting in trouble
they kind of oh my God yeah you know as
long as you can handle it it's good
growth for the city I mean it's creating
more jobs and stuff like that you know
what I'm saying I feel like a terrible
City to be a rookie in yeah for sure
Henry rugs but I think is it good
because um man growing up
everybody you've seen in Vegas that was
had fancy cars a big jury stuff was
either dope boys or pimps for sure
so now you know what I'm saying and I
know that because
um I've had several conversations with
people and they was like man when I seen
you driving there I knew I could get in
I was like what I didn't really think it
was that much of a big deal you know
what I'm saying but hearing people say
that that was like damn so if they
thought that about me imagining what
they think about the Raiders or somebody
like that you know what I'm saying so
it's a good thing